[MUSIC]
My ride back from work, on June 3rd,
2017, was not your typical commute.
I was in the back seat
of a white pickup truck,
with temperatures outside
edging up to 115 degrees.
The roof of our car was painted
with a humanitarian symbol so
that we wouldn't be hit by an airstrike.
That summer, I was an aid worker
in Northern Iraq during the final
stages of the operation
against Isis in Mosul.
After a ten-hour day in the fields,
covered in dust,
all I wanted was to get home and
take a cold shower.
But the day wasn't over yet.
As my colleagues and I made our way home,
we started hearing reports that
neighborhoods in Mosul were
filling with poisonous gas.
Twitter was lighting up with
these cell phone images showing
aircraft firing white sprays
of smoke into the city.
It was quickly identified
as white phosphorus used by
the US-led coalition and the Iraqi army.
White phosphorus can be
used legitimately or
more as a smoke screen to
obscure military movements.
But when humans come into contact with it,
it can also burn flesh off of the bone.
So depending on how it's used,
it can either be a totally legitimate
tactic of war or war crime.
And sometimes it's nearly
impossible to tell the difference.
My colleagues began to argue.
Should we demand
an international outcry for
the coalitions use of chemicals
in a densely populated city?
Or given that it’s a grey area,
should we focus energy on other problems?
It was a judgment call.
A decision made by a handful
of well meaning humanitarians.
We decided not to push it.
I was left confused by the whole incident.
How could something as weighty
as a war crime be so slippery?
So hard to pin down.
Back in the States, I began studying
war crimes, and I quickly learnt
that there's no clear answer, and
the technology of war is evolving so
quickly, the question is
only becoming more urgent.
The concept of war crimes originates
in the earliest eras of human history.
Ancient codes of war from China, India and
Greece, regulated troops conduct.
Today, the laws have all provide
guidance on who qualifies as combatants,
the limits of the battlefields and
what sorts of acts are permissible.
Troops must wear uniforms,
they should avoid civilians,
they can't torture prisoners,
things like that.
When you think about it,
it's actually kind of bizarre.
Acts that would ordinarily land you in
jail, like taking someone's life or
destroying a building,
are totally legal if you're at war.
But even in war, there is
a category of actions that humanity
had decided is beyond the pale,
and those we call war crimes.
We even have tribunals that attempt
to being perpetrators to justice.
Like following the Rwandan genocide or
ethnic cleansing in the Balkans.
To me,
there's something profound about humans
attempting to being integrity and
ethics into battle.
But in practice, it's not so
easy to draw the line.
Partially because world's
feeling messy and chaotic, but
also because it turns out there is no
clear universal definition of a war crime.
Ask any international lawyer and
you'll get this circular answer,
a war crime is a serious
violation of the laws of war.
What's a serious violation
the laws of war?
A war crime.
As a result, historically courts
have sometimes struggled to decide,
is terrorism a war crime?
Is rape?
Is recruiting child soldiers?
If you think it's confusing now,
it's about to get a whole lot worse.
Technology being developed
right here in Silicon Valley,
artificial intelligence,
autonomous vehicles, drones,
is the same technology that
will dictate the future of war.
And it's evolving so rapidly,
it's already outpaced the law.
We're headed for a legal black hole,
where anything goes.
In particular,
technology is complicating the three
areas where law used to provide clarity.
Who are the combatants, where is
the battlefield, and what are the harms?
First, who are the commandants?
Picture a fully autonomous
AI power weapon system.
To be clear, this doesn't exist yet,
but it's not inconceivable.
It's been pre-programmed to strike enemy
targets without human intervention,
it may actually be more precise and
accurate, less prompt to error.
But it's imperfect.
And let's say it somehow
commits a horrendous act like
targeting a hospital
instead of a military base.
Who can be held responsible?
Technology creates a massive
accountability gap.
War crimes are committed by combatants but
are computer programmers and
manufacturers commands?
Unless it could be proven that they
were somehow aware of the defect,
they're simply too far
remove from the crime.
And would it even be fair to
charge an engineer in Palo Alto
with war crimes committed
halfway along the globe.
Second, where is the battlefield?
Imagine a nuclear explosion in space,
creates an electromagnetic pulse that
reaches Earth's atmosphere,
causing aircraft to fall from the sky.
Or imagine a cyber attack launched
from a suburban living room.
That wipes out a power
grid in another country.
The law of work tries to keep
destruction on the battlefields, but
there's no standalone regulation
of warfare and space, and
there's no consensus on
the limits of cyber war.
Wars of the future will rarely look like
two armies meeting on the battlefields,
where we'll beef up from
remote locations and
it will be carried out in outer spance and
in digital space.
And third, what are the harms?
The law of work usually conceives
a harm in terms of physical damage,
violence, bloodshed, destruction.
But new weapons will cause different
harms, like environmental damage.
Imagine a weapon leaves behind toxic
remnants that slowly destroys farm land,
leaving it inhospitable.
Or imagine a cyber attack
that destroys information,
medical records, financial data.
We haven't yet decided if those sorts
of harms should be off limit and were.
There's a work crime require
physical pain, physical destruction.
These questions are not easily answered.
The law of work was created before
artificial intelligence even before
the Internet.
We're retrofitting rules from the 19th and
20th century to a new world.
And frankly, these are questions
that no one wants to think about.
The latest version of the United States
official guidelines on autonomous
weapons is no more than a couple page
PDF document with track changes left on.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's terrifying.
Some say it's not worth establishing legal
guidelines if you're not sure that we can
hold people accountable anyway.
Some say that regulation
will stifle innovation.
I say, it's a cop out,
I don't have all the answers.
But my instinct is that war is and
should remain a uniquely human endeavor.
There should be meaningful human
control over life and death decisions.
For sure, technology can do
a lot to improve defense and
reduce risk for
service members and civilians.
But we can never fully delegate
moral agency to a machine.
And we should resist
the temptation to try.
At Stanford, we're tasked with
thinking up the unimaginable.
A new business idea,
the moon shot invention.
The sobering side of that mandate is
the duty to also consider the harms.
What the adverse actor might
do if given a chance or
the well meaning actor who
simply has no legal guidance.
This isn't limited to welfare,
ethic should be a central component of all
technology design not an after thought.
The mere act of writing down standards
helps to build the consensus on
what's acceptable, and what isn't.
We can't trust that existing
law has all of the answers,
as is clear with war crimes,
but may have very few.
War is a tragic reality, but
the decisions we make today can ensure
that it is constrained to the battlefield
and the soldiers who fight on it.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]